>> So, the second alternative I just wanted
to mention very briefly is something called LDA, which
is short for linear discriminant analysis. So, any
guess on what linear discriminant analysis might do, Michael?
>> It'll make, well, linear. So it's got a
linear in it. Discriminant reminds me of, like, classification lines.
>> Yes. So, what linear discriminant analysis
does is, it finds a projection that
discriminates based on the label. This actually will feel, this
feels a lot like supervised learning, right? You take advantage
of the label, and you come up with a transformation,
such that you will, in fact, project things into different
clumps or clusters, or otherwise separate them based upon their
label. So, you can imagine using a lot of algorithms,
as we've used in the past. In some sense, what
they're doing is, linear discriminant analysis. They're finding lines or
finding linear separators between different clumps of points. And
if you think about the binary case, for example,
you could think of SVM as doing something like
this, where what you've done is, you transform your points
not into a specific label plus or minus, one
or zero, yes or no, but you instead project it
onto the line such that it would clump things
accordingly. And you use the value of that projection as
a way of re-representing the data. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, and this, this approach seems a
little different from all the other ones, in
that it's actually paying attention to how the
resulting components are going to get used. Right.
>> That's exactly right.
>> It actually is going to try
to help you, specifically, with the classification.
>> Alright, that's exactly right. All three
of the examples that we gave before,
feel almost like filter methods, right? In
that they have some criterion they're trying
to maximize. Even though randomized projections is, who knows
what it's trying to maximize besides randomness. But they
don't care about the ultimate learner, or the ultimate
label that's associated with them. Whereas LDA does care explicitly
about the labels and wants to find ways to
discriminate, finds sort of projections or features that make it
easier for you to do that discrimination. Now it
also does not care about what learner's going to happen next,
but it does care about the label. So
it does end up doing something slightly different, and
works pretty well in a world where you have
very simple things that can be lineraly discriminated. Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> So that's it for the alternatives. I actually think that's pretty
much it for, feature transformation. So why don't we wrap up. [CROSSTALK]
>> Just a quick, just a quick question, though. [CROSSTALK] So, LDA, I've
heard of LDA in this context before
meaning something else. Like, latent Dirichlet allocation?
Yeah, but that happened long after linear discriminant
analysis and we haven't moved past the 90s.
>> Well, I'm just saying that it does seem.
And I think it is actually an unsupervised approach.
>> Oh latent, oh no, absolutely. But it is well
beyond the scope of the discussion that we're going to have here.
>> All right. As you wish.
>> But it is in fact. Every time you see a D you can think Dirichlet.
>> Which is the computer science
pronunciation. Other people pronounce it differently.
>> Yes, because the correct way of pronouncing
it is sort of beyond my. It has another
syllable in there. Is it German or something?
>> Yeah.
>> Who is Dirichlet. Is it Dirichlet? [LAUGH] That
sounded German. [LAUGH] Okay, so let's wrap up Michael.
>> Alright.
>> Okay.